I want to know how to do the awesome
glasses trick that you do in the movie
because that was the coolest thing I've
ever seen you're literally there on your
head and you're like oh thank you for
noticing that
it was like I do that I want do you
really yeah dude that's pretty cool
doing you've got a stem oh that's good
thank you ii want your head but these
are like you know my glasses says they
won't stick proclick is it yeah but
you're like hit them on your hand mining
will just stay there and you go I will
never be as cool as you but it's okay
I've accepted it you'll be cooling your
own weight I want to talk about the
casting in this movie because it's
incredible especially seeing the film
and you know you kind of see the adults
and the kids going back and forth what
did you think of you know working
opposite Jaden I heard there was a
little speed date and getting to know
each other
yes speed dated with a bunch of barely
pubescent mm-hmm Hollywood's messed up
and it was it was like we did like a
little five minutes with this loser and
then we'd swap loser and then loser swap
swap and then it was kind of a cool way
to get around everybody but your nose
with you respect I'm barely getting
started with you and then no more to you
it was it was a cool thing to do the
weirdest thing about this felt in the
Brillion thing that's doing this film is
it usually you build a backstory in the
whole history but I got to watch a whole
movie of my history and my backstory I
have like really realized with
orchestral music memories of my
character as played by Jaden and that's
something I've never had before weird
the mix it strangely sentimental to
watch the movie again it's it's crazy
cuz it's only two films but I feel like
there's such a special you know
connection with those kids in that cast
yeah this is your third time like
working with Jessica Chastain
technically my fourth really oh yeah cuz
the the - yeah yeah yeah I got you but I
heard she signed on first so was that
kind of was that part of the pool that
got you yeah well I went to see the
movie in Montreal went with Nicholas who
went for burger and movie night and and
then the next day we're in movie making
eggs
I'm doing a scene with Jess and see what
do you think it's been a really
licensure that's good it was that wide
so because the director really want you
to play bill and that was it I was like
yes but I'm you don't necessarily take
it the pinch of salt because you hear a
lot of things as an actor throughout
your career that you're going to do this
or somebody's got this for you
you definitely cast in this even
sometimes do the deals you know I mean
and then you know in the phone so I was
away I won't get too excited but I was
like alright great secretly I was
excited but then and then like two
months later Dundee one touch me was
like yeah really mean it I'm gonna do
this I was like yes what a person I want
to talk about another franchise because
you recently wrapped up you know playing
Professor X and it's such a special you
know franchise for you I'm curious you
know if you knew it was coming to a
close and if there's anything further
you would have wanted to do with that
character obviously we're gonna write
something interesting I'd always be
happy to carry on playing that character
I guess that's not necessarily true I
don't know never wouldn't it's long as
you were doing something new and
interesting and finding a new way to
explore the character and the world
actually then yes tons of legs and there
are still tons of legs in the world of
mutants and I'm looking forward to
seeing what it goes yeah it was a
special thing for me I loved it as a fan
of it before I got involved in it and
never thought I'd get to sit in that
chair literally sit in that chair
and yeah I think last time I talked to
you you were you were bald showboating
would you ever do another comic book
movie cuz Marvel's pretty notorious for
being like we like these actors we want
to put them in it if it was good if it
was you know I've already sort of seen a
couple of things come my way that I
haven't done the on because I wasn't
interested in you know the role
very interesting and obvious as a whole
thing but no I mean I'm just anything
doing good roles in good stories so if
it's a good role and it's a good story
and it happens to be a comment regarding
then that's just by the bone
[Music]